hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
seeing how we are nearing the end of
Schwarzenegger run down let's go get
down get down
very thankfully I was trying to think of
what's the best film to end on Annie
Arnold's already fought savages
terrorism the horrifying threat of
pregnancy what else is there left to
fight for yes in 1999 some numbnut
figure it was time for Schwarzenegger
and the Horde one himself to do get out
at end of days is it as awesome as it
sounds uh no but it is as lame as it
sounds and isn't that enough reason to
celebrate I'm gonna lie to you and say
yes yes it is so let's see how the Lord
of Darkness competes with the Lord of
Austrians in end of days so it starts
out in the most horrible and terrifying
year this film can conjure up the Carter
years
I'm gonna stay yes before the church had
to worry about The Da Vinci Code being
overrated they were concerned about the
eye of God which is a sign indicating
that the mother of the Antichrist will
be boring and wouldn't you know it
she is right in New York beautiful baby
girl but the baby is taken out of the
mother's hands for a bit so that this
can be performed
I guess laughing the baby is no longer
our practice we've been cut to 20 years
later on the verge of the new year as
the devil himself decides to return to
earth how does he choose to do this by
blowing up some sewers flying around an
invisible gargoyle and possessing v-not
Keyser söze from usual suspects hell are
you
whoa Gabriel Byrne I'm sorry continued
groping my wife hey everybody
Gabriel Byrne is dropping my wife oh boy
this is the happiest day of so yeah this
isn't the devil that tries to feed the
subtle sadness or filled anger in the
heart of men no this is a devil who
likes to blow shit up and turn into
monsters I go where's Arnold
Schwarzenegger when you need away he's
playing the typical depressed ex-cop
as you always see them messy room check
blinds closed check pointing a gun at
his head but too afraid to pull the
trigger check don't I need to Prescott
eat ice cream but Kevin Pollak comes in
dressed as Kevin Pollak as he tries to
lighten Arnold spirits so what's the day
transport anyone special
now just some Wall Street scumbag the
hell does he need orders protection
personally I like scumbags big deal who
hasn't had a coffee beer Penta fizzle
Chinese food and pizza Slurpee or as I
like to call it kaboom so it turns out
Schwarzenegger and Pollock our body
guards protecting oddly enough terrible
no guess the Lord of Darkness is afraid
to let my throne Agana or something and
Lord knows Arnold knows a lot about
fighting bills you won't shoot up but as
luck would have it someone is trying to
take him out is Arnold Impala chasing
down Hey Arnold say it no come on just
say it more I'll pay you 50 bucks if you
say it ha get to the choppa you just
made me salute
got man
we're in an Arnold Schwarzenegger puppet
show I got no strings to hold me down to
make me fret or make me proud
I have strings behind me there are no
strings on me
oh come on you can jump out of a plane
and land faster than these guys are
oh yeah he's fine he's fine just fell
several stories crashed through a glass
Juan landed on newspaper stand just walk
it off walk it off so he chases him into
a train tunnel where you start shouting
some crazy nonsense hey Doc hey George
Lucas Griffin get down on the ground
thousand years Avenger you don't know
what you've done
well the bum was a priest talk about the
faith going to your head I mean how many
bum priests are there oh my gosh but new
team a new Domino's Pizza your works in
mysterious ways
it's your only friend you change change
ha ha ha so as they take him away they
discover something very interesting
about him and you said here the guy
spoke to you yeah so what the guy
doesn't have a tongue neither do i but
that doesn't stop me from speaking ah ha
ha ha so to get some answers they take a
look at where the bum lives looks like
milk Gibson's house
yeah who by God that was the scariest
non scary thing I've ever seen this guy
is no ordinary hit men no this one's
extraordinary let's get the hell out of
here in this place is making me itch how
can help you to find this plane lucky
guess
so what did you find out well nothing
compared to the cat meanwhile on the
subway a young woman named Christine
sits down while an exploding cheese ball
here seems to watch her closely he's
coming for you he's coming for you
Christine
how do you know my name he's kind of
fuck you he's gonna fuck you Christy
how do you know my name oh my god it's a
human Jenga
I guess I'm very fragile it turns out
it's just all in her head or is it yeah
yeah oh but why well Arnold tries to go
to the church the bum worked at to see
if he can get some answers
excuse me I'm sorry we're closed please
use the drive-through confessional I
would like to talk to you about Thomas
Aquinas was he looking for someone
yes you're working for God so God
ordered a hit on an investment bank it's
an awful lot that you don't know you
think you've seen everything you haven't
there are things you never dreamed of
there's another world out there and it
destroyed I'm sorry I only speak in
movie trailer quotes there's another
world out there these are things you
can't possibly understand in a world
ruled by fear he took a chance and dared
to dream again all day so he tells
Arnold to piss off and go with God as he
ventures downstairs
sure Oh what's up silly maybe the priest
should have locked the door before
looking at this incredibly shocking stop
how can the secret organisation forget
to lock up friggin door get out and
forget what you've seen
Thomas Potter for the sources here at
work you couldn't possibly comprehend
our world is changing you cannot stop
what you cannot kill this summer the
biggest blockbuster of all time will be
revealed meanwhile Christine has yet
another vision this one's up Gabriel
Byrne who I guess likes having sex
through osmosis
while her stepmother tries to comfort
her we see that someone has visited a
bum priest and apparently was not very
pleased with it
now light so crucified the patient mark
I'm telling you know what enter the room
maybe did it himself wait a minute what
maybe did it himself maybe he did it
himself
oh yeah these self crucifixions happen
all the time don't they
hell I got a woman down the street
crucified herself every Thursday cash I
got a nail her feet to the ground in
order to make her stop not literally and
how did he get the last scalpel in the
real question is why are you arguing
this Oh Satan shall be loosed out of his
prison Christ in New York
ha
oh good
no thought the thing that upset me after
that scene we come to Christie who's
just getting done with her work end
hello pointless press shot goodbye
pointless fresh shot but you know since
her Butler has not been doing a good job
cleaning up his mess but maybe that's
because he is the mess nobody expects
the Spanish Inquisition
so he's religious nut jobs come in and
try to kill Christine while Arnold and
Pollock hear her screaming outside go
down to do whatever you can I need more
time to finish the last rites hi Christ
see that's the problem with prayers they
always take too long can you just send
even rubba-dub-dub killed your Butler in
the tub forever amen yeah maybe big
dramatic stabs aren't the answer either
moron you're killing a person not doing
tight ball
take it easy we are the good guys
alright what happened you know what do
you think this woman writes in her blog
you think it sounds weird so this week I
went shopping a man disintegrated before
my eyes I was raped by Gabriel Byrne and
several priests tried to kill me
all in all on the lucky girl so I don't
decide to look after her as he tries to
put the pieces to this mystery together
Christine what are you doing why is that
man here I'll be five minutes she loves
me to death but she's a little
overprotective she I can't imagine why
it's not like anyone put a hit out on
you or anything the men that attacked me
are devil worshippers no this says did
the good guys
so in probably the weirdest way to kill
a guy Gabriel Byrne pisses on the
sidewalk it leaks into Kevin Pollak's
van and he lights his own urine on fire
then give him a neighbor a strike from
this
I don't know Christine try to get out
but I don't get this is beat up by the
middle-aged stepmother oh come on I know
you're not that out of shape a
three-legged poodle could take on this
woman Christine please tell your mommy
to stop beating me up it heard after he
finally smashes the old bag they make
their way back to the church Eve is
ative before to try and get some more
answers with after her well if you'll
excuse me I'll try to explain you know
anything about the number of the beast
revelation of st. John from his dream
666 the number of the beast is not 666
often their dreams numbers appear upside
down backward so 666 becomes 9 9 9 like
in 1999 the year of his return wow
that's a really big stretch their movie
I mean you're really desperate aren't
you oh hell why stop there
see how there's three digits and I
divide by 3 is 3 the one in the
beginning seems to come out of nowhere
so let's check but then the middle you
add 9 9 9 together you get 21 when you
take one number away because you added
the number before therefore you have to
subtract the number as well put them
together connect them to heirs of the
alphabet and you get God so Arnall tries
to sum up what the priest is say so the
Prince of Darkness
once the conquer the earth but is to
wait until an hour before midnight of
New Year's Eve well gee when you put it
like that it sounds absolutely retarded
it doesn't matter whether you believe or
not he's real and he won't rest till he
finds this good why'd he pick me because
the stars were right when you were born
oh yeah because nobody else was born at
that point in time yeah how many babies
are born every minute on this planet
there you go Satan take your pick of a
letter the slutty ones are usually
better so she decides to stay with the
priest as Arnold goes home or Bern is
waiting for you what do you want to make
you have
okay so he offers to bring back his wife
and daughter from their untimely deaths
if he only tells him where Christie is
so yeah he can bring people back from
the dead
turn piss into fire and yet he can't
just find one stinking woman the Lord of
Darkness is a bit of a dumbass isn't he
you don't want to shame me up shit so
Otto refuses his offer and burn doesn't
take it very well are you gonna do is
take my hand
and I'll give you back everything that
he took away okay yeah Wow
the devil really fell for that I thought
maybe the devil would be just a tad bit
smarter it turns out kevin pollak also
returns even though we saw him blow up
and we know he's obviously a bad guy but
don't tell Arnold yet he's a bit slow
but luckily some more priests come in to
help Christine in her battle we've come
to help your evidence how's it go girls
fine thanks nope
quelle fool me once shame on you fool me
twice
end of days ha ha ha what's with you
mine come ah but Arnold comes in to stop
them as the devil it's not far behind
kevin pollak in the meantime kidnaps
Christine because oh he's working for
the devil now Wow what a shocker
as he lease Arnold to be beaten by a
bunch of the Devils me
boy look up thought I'd be crucified
twice in my career this is a weird job
so like every stupid ruler of evil he
doesn't kill Arnold
which means this allows him to go to the
police station to load up and haul ass
Ruthy so he makes it to the black mass
where Bern plans to pregnant Christie
Arnold says hasta LaVista Rosemary's
Baby as he shoots his way to the altar
no one move I killed a girl you're not
gonna kill her you said it yourself of a
dark heart then stand with me
don't make me continue my William Dafoe
impression so Arnold shoot some more as
they make their way into the New York
subway map of course in typical New York
fashion has absolutely nobody on it
yes
how are you doing no it's okay it's the
devil
have I mentioned yet how much this devil
sucks
gotta go
yeah boy I'm really bad at this I can
see why I was a fallen angel
cuz I'm falling over everything
so they make their way back to the
church again as Arnold tells Christine
to hide just hide so he prepares to
finally face off with the devil by doing
what else pray oh come on
Arnold this is neither the time nor the
place
it was strengthened
if you do not listen then the hell with
you so the devil does what he should
have done all along turn into a devil
when this have been over a lot sooner if
he just did that to begin with
so he possesses Arnold's body in order
to get to Christie and like a doofus she
falls for it we were I think we should
celebrate with a victory screw nothing
is wrong you died for nothing but Arnold
goodwill shines through as he fights the
devil off from the inside and stamps
himself on a sword heartburn
direct I've been foiled by the power of
love
so Arnold sees his wife and daughter
again as he goes to that happy
California in the sky the end what a
stupid movie you think something like
Arnold Schwarzenegger versus the devil
would be something cool but it's not
it's unbelievably like the action is not
good it's not scary there's like a
bajillion Platt hold it's just not that
entertaining fan father that we all know
who would really solve the problem if
they just gave him a call Santa Christ
Santa
Oh Santa Christ Satan the Lord of
Darkness I'm trying to take over the
world could you do something about that
sure food critic wow you turned him into
a box of ho ho homes I certainly did oh
thanks again Santa Christ you're the
best problem critic here have a Sega
Genesis oh wow just the best person the
world Santa Christ and is there anything
you're afraid of anything at all
thanks for watching sports negamatter
100 episode next week down
yeah